[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sotheby's welt
heute wird gegrillt und zwar gibt es
käse mit cevapcici und selbstgemachtem
das rezept ist super denn ihr könnt
alles perfekt vorbereiten und dann zum
beispiel auch zur grillfeier mitnehmen
das eiweiß oder konservieren also back
um ihren und daneben auch über mehrere
wochen haltbar machen und ich zeige euch
jetzt zuerst mal tagen für cyber
verwende ich eine aubergine 2 rohde
späth paprika eine zwiebel 2
knoblauchzehen 50 gramm olivenöl salz
und pfeffer chili und eine prise zucker
für das ei wird jetzt das gemüse
gegrillt das heißt ich nehme jetzt die
aubergine
die können die entweder im ganzen lassen
oder damit schneller geht halbieren und
dann mit der schlitz seite nach unten
auf dem backblech setzen und die spielt
paprika direkt sich einfach nur so ein
bisschen ein
so platzte nicht
und das kommt jetzt beides hier auf dem
grill und wird dann bei 220 grad für
ungefähr 45 bis 60 minuten gebacken bis
die oberfläche blasen wird also bei den
paprika die wird richtig schön dunkel
die aubergine wird diese schon schwarz
aber die wird noch dunkler und richtig
weich und das aroma wird vor allem ganz
ganz toll
[Musik]
die zutaten fürs kann ich mal zur seite
stellen und jetzt eigentlich schon mal
die cevapcici masse herstellen für die
hackfleisch masse brauche ich 600 gramm
hackfleisch vom rind ich habe 100 gramm
silber brösel ein eine große zwiebel und
knoblauchzehe jedoch die gewürze salz
pfeffer chili etwas paprikapulver
edelsüß kreuzkümmel einen viertel bund
petersilie und etwas sonnenblumenöl die
zwiebel und knoblauchzehen die schäl ich
jetzt und dann werde ich sie fein reiben
ich kenne es ja auch ganz fein hacken
auch richter was die akzeptanz
ich reiße ihn einfach in ganz feine
würfel
ich werde doch fein reiben die ziemlich
echt heftig ich will jetzt nicht fein
hacken sonst muss ich ganz alleine
also ich halbiert oder viertels jetzt
noch kurz die hard power und dann werde
ich sie kurz in der küchenmaschine
reiben
[Musik]
tränen schon und das hat nichts gebracht
muss trotzdem einen score jetzt kommt
man die zwiebel und knoblauchzehe hier
oben gerade jetzt halt immer das gleiche
ich glaube ich dass sich da in zukunft
auf zwiebeln warum ich so weit geht
kommt hier das hackfleisch dazu ihr
könnt das jetzt auch einfach mit den
händen verkneten auf man riechen die
hände hans hug nach zwiebeln die gebe
ich jetzt auch semmelbrösel dazu immer
erst mal ein bisschen weniger dann das
ei die gewürze und jetzt paket ich schon
mal alles und kann dann in der
zwischenzeit die petersilie
[Musik]
ich benutze jetzt hier nur die blätter
die stille weil ich jetzt später hackeln
die kann ich dann einfach einfrieren
hier wird hier die petersilie dazu wenn
es kann sein dass man auch regional
cevapcici nicht so macht ich muss euch
sagen dass ich so genannte nie gegessen
habe denn da ist ja noch schreien
mitarbeiter das essen wir nicht das ist
jetzt ebenso die helle wände die
getürkten kostenfreies gemischt
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich hier das öl bestreichen
ein bisschen das im mai blech damit und
auch meine hände dann wird sich nämlich
einfacher formen und ich nehme jetzt
einen großen eis portionierer so kann
ich immer gleichmäßige portionen
abstechen und dann einfach in den händen
formen und ich meine kräfte oder
frikadelle oder dramatisch wie im grunde
sind halt immer einfach wenn die
küchlein und gewürze sind halt immer ein
bisschen anders aber da müsst ihr
einfach entscheiden welche gewählten
habt so magazin eine längliche form und
leg dich jetzt ringsum hin und nehmen
einfach immer so viel wie eben in diesem
großen 1 portionierer passt
[Musik]
jetzt sind sie fertig wenn ich kann sehr
abdecken dafür nehme ich einfach das
andere im blech und gibt dir jetzt so in
den kühlschrank und kann dann den
letzten zeit schon mal die zwiebel und
knoblauchzehe schälen und fein würfeln
[Musik]
die paprika und die auberginen sind
jetzt schön weich und da ziehe ich jetzt
einfach die haut ab und gebe das
fruchtfleisch hier in den teller
[Musik]
kerner lasse ich hier auch mit drin die
sind im heim nicht super lecker
[Musik]
bei der aubergine löffel ich es einfach
raus
[Musik]
was eigentlich sage ich immer wenn ihr
euch schon die mühe macht und herstellt
macht gleich eine riesenmenge
da können dann nämlich alles in gläser
apfel und habt immer einfach auf vorrat
das war jetzt aber so die menge die
jetzt hier auch zum cevapcici und zum
grill käse passt also so für die
portionen größe es gebe ich das olivenöl
in einem topf könnte auch eine pfanne
nehmen
da werden jetzt die zwiebel und
knoblauch würflein gebraten
das brauch will ich sagen zwiebel und
knoblauch zwei blau also immer wenn ich
jetzt zwiebel und knoblauch bewusst
sagen einfach zwei blau und die werden
jetzt angebraten wisse glasig sind und
was ich vor allem noch vergessen hat zu
erwähnen ich brauche noch ein bisschen
paprika mag das 100 den geschmack noch
mal gut ab jetzt hier einfach mit einer
kirchen schere ein bisschen verkleinern
wenn ich schon im thema drin habe mache
ich das so wie bei l aus spaghetti immer
die besitzer kleiner
hier gebe ich jetzt das paprika markt
dazu und statt paprika markt können wir
auch der tomatenmark nehmen paprika
markt macht das ein bisschen witziger
und tomatenmark ein bisschen fruchtiger
[Musik]
das gebe ich hier das gemüse dazu
tomaten passen auch immer ganz gut dazu
jetzt gerade noch ein bissle köcheln
lassen und dann mit den gewürzen
abschmecken und beim paprika putzen wort
heute beim paprika man muss man
aufpassen denn das hat meist schon sein
also vorher dann lieber erstmal
abschmecken und dann noch salz zufügen
[Musik]
jetzt ist der tipp im prinzip schon
fertig und ich kann ihn einfach in
gläser abfüllen und wenn ihr sie
wirklich dann noch aufbewahren wollen
schön fest verschließen damit sich ein
vakuum bildet und dann ist es einmal
wirklich mehrere wochen haltbar wenn ich
einmal hersteller dann mache ich gleich
eine riesenportion für saab in kleine
gläser verschließe sie
und dann kommt sie in die bauspar com
schublade der ganze sauerstoff die ganze
luft wird rausgezogen und dann ist es
wirklich mega lange haltbar
[Musik]
perfekt ich habe jetzt noch keinen grill
auf der terrasse des wegen mir heute
wieder hier drinnen in der küche auf der
grillplatte aber auf dem grill geht es
natürlich auch die grillplatte die werde
ich jetzt ein bisschen vettel etwas
vermittlungen öl und dann kann ich
gleich die cevapcici dürfte die
frikadellen grillen einfach rundherum
wenn man keine schöne kruste bekommen
und dann nehme ich hier noch dem grill
und pfannen käse
der passt jetzt auch perfekt dazu den
werde ich es aber dritter den gibt es
auch in verschiedenen
geschmacksrichtungen wie ich nehm jetzt
natur
[Musik]
da kann ich jetzt den käse und auch die
therapie schön anbraten
[Musik]
jetzt dürfen unserem lehrer und murat
probieren
ich finde es einfach genial wie auch
schon
mehr braucht man gar nicht mal so ein
bisschen köpfte also ich habe jetzt
cevapcici gewarnt und kollegen der form
und dann noch rivic okay dass ich
schluss auf ja betrieb frau und ich
hab's marconi hat deswegen ja auch schon
was du bist ein starker mann ist hast du
das auf kriegs orient gabel und messer
also probiert mal zum ihrer greift immer
gleich zum käse aber die fleischbällchen
much auge durch die schmelze samira
schwere krise ist und eher leichte
gleich und ich bin ja klar wenn er da
werd die wird es jetzt auch das ist
alles schon nie gemacht werden doch
richtig gut da draußen auf den grill
machen aber wir haben auch keine das
müssen wir besorgen bei mir auch noch
keine garten wir glaubten im netz
das kriegen wir noch und ich finde auf
der kelle platte recht ganz cool
[Musik]
auch ich cool großen kombi gut und der
käse als würzig schmeckt ja und es
einfach hammer durch ich komme doch
nicht blöd weil es schmeckt einfach ja
nein ich hatte auch einige schlimme auf
immer zu sagen es schmeckt auch wenn ich
muss er ist zu 98 prozent auszumachen
das freut mich und hier auch gut ich
habe es einfach das spiel zu scharf für
dich des browsers ist das rezept auch
mit dem eiweiss gemacht ja also
praktisch de web de mit bahn und dazu
grillkäse und ich finde es schon so eine
schöne kombi war halt was würziges
frikadellen dann den großen käse und
dann eben diese das cremige schafe aber
passt gut als einfach brot dazu wer will
mir wird jetzt auch so schon reichen
ohne brot noch ein grüner salat und
meint grill wäre komplettes waren
produkte ja wo ich war ein schönes waren
wir ein schönes raums baum da gibt es
auch schon ein rezept auf einem kanal
wenn ihr das nachmacht dann verlinke
mich gerne probiert gerne mal aus und
ich wünsche euch viel spaß dabei das
rezept findet er auch so ließ - blog.de
und wir sind wieder hört das nächste mal
und ich nicht gleich küste und cevapcici
ich bin noch andere gewürze und andere
gewürze wohltat sagen weil die gewürze
mal ganz anders was du gemacht hast
richtig lag ihr könnt gerne mal
schreiben welches grillrezepte euch noch
fehlt
[Musik]